>> Tucker: NO SHOW ON
TELEVISION, I THINK IT’S FAIR TO
SAY, HAS MOCKED CHRIS CUOMO MORE
LETHALLY THAN THIS ONE HAS, BUT
TONIGHT WE WILL TAKE A BREAK
FROM THAT.
TONIGHT HE ANNOUNCED HE’S BEEN
INFECTED BY THE CORONAVIRUS.
HE SAID HE’S HAD FEVER AND
SHORTNESS OF BREATH BUT HIS MAIN
WORRY WAS INFECTING HIS WIFE AND
CHILDREN.
THOSE ARE THE RIGHT PRORATE
OHMIC PRIORITIES.
HE SAID HE WILL CONTINUE TO DO
HIS SHOW AS LONG AS HE CAN FROM
ISOLATION IN HIS BASEMENT.
WE RESPECT THAT, TOO.
GODSPEED TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY.
WE ARE ROOTING FOR YOU.
CORONAVIRUS HAS CRUSHED OUR ONCE
THRIVING ENERGY SECTOR WHICH IS
IN A LOT OF WAYS THE CORE OF OUR
ECONOMY NO MATTER WHAT THEY TELL
YOU.
EARLIER THIS MONTH SAUDI ARABIA
BEGAN AN ORAL PRICE WAR WITH
RUSSIA AND THAT SET THE PRICE OF
OIL CRASHING.
NOW WIDESPREAD SHUTDOWNS MEAN
FEWER CARS ON THE ROAD, FEWER
FLIGHTS UNLESS INDUSTRIAL
ACTIVITY WHICH MEANS LESS DEMAND
FOR OIL, LOWER PRICES AND BAD
NEWS FOR AMERICA’S ENERGY’S
PRODUCERS.
IT MEANS GOOD NEWS FOR YOU IF
YOU USE GASOLINE AND WE ARE FOR
THAT COMPLETELY.
BUT WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF OUR
ENERGY SECTOR COLLAPSED?
THAT’S SOMETHING WE MAY NEED TO
THINK ABOUT.
THAT’S A BIG QUESTION.
RICK PERRY SPENT CLOSE TO THREE
YEARS AS A PRESIDENT SECRETARY
OF ENERGY AND WAS THE GOVERNOR
FOR THREE TERMS OF TEXAS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
SO IT’S PRETTY CLEAR THAT THE
ENERGY SECTOR IS REALLY
THREATENED AND ALMOST NOBODY
REFLEXIVELY SUPPORTS OIL
REFINERIES OR WHATEVER.
BUT THIS SEEMS LIKE A REAL
THREAT.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF THAT SECTOR
COLLAPSED?
>> TUCKER, I THINK IT’S
IMPORTANT FOR YOUR VIEWERS TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT, WHAT IS THE
ENERGY INDUSTRY AND WHO IS THE
ENERGY INDUSTRY?
IT’S THE UNION WORKERS IN
PENNSYLVANIA AND AT STATE
WORKERS IN THE TEXAS GULF COAST.
IT’S THOSE WORKERS IN THE
PERMIAN BASIN AND IN THE BUCKET
IN NORTH DAKOTA, IN PENNSYLVANIA
AND THE PIPELINE WORKERS OUT
THERE.
THERE IS OF AMERICANS WHO, THEIR
ENTIRE FUTURE AND TAKING CARE OF
THEIR FAMILY AND PLAYING THEIR
MORTGAGES IS TIED DIRECTLY TO
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY.
IT’S A DRIVER OF A MASSIVE
AMOUNT OF OUR AMERICAN ECONOMY.
THERE ARE SOME BIG COMPANIES OUT
THERE, THERE ARE INDEPENDENTS
OUT THERE THAT ARE THE REAL
BUFFER.
BUT HERE’S WHAT YOU NEED TO KEEP
IN MIND.
IF WE WERE TO LOSE THOSE
INDEPENDENT OPERATORS AND WE ARE
ON THE VERGE, LET ME TELL YOU.
OUR CAPACITY IS FULL AND THE
SAUDIS ARE FLOODING THIS MARKET
WITH CHEAP OIL, AND I’M TELLING
YOU, WE ARE ON THE VERGE OF A
MASSIVE COLLAPSE OF AN INDUSTRY
THAT WE WORKED AWFULLY HARD OVER
THE COURSE OF THE LAST THREE OR
FOUR YEARS TO BUILD UP TO THE
NUMBER ONE OIL AND GAS PRODUCING
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, GIVING
AMERICANS SOME AFFORDABLE ENERGY
RESOURCES.
IF WE WERE TO LOSE THAT, IF WE
WOKE UP ONE YEAR FROM NOW AND
THERE WERE FIVE BIG COMPANIES
BECAUSE THERE’S A COMPANY CALLED
REMCO AND A COMPANY CALLED ROSS
MET WITH THE RUSSIANS,
EXXONMOBIL, CHEVRON CHEVRON AND
MAYBE BP, IF THAT’S IT THEN I
WOULD SUGGEST THAT WOULD MAKE A
LOT OF AMERICANS REALLY NERVOUS
THAT THAT IS THE ONLY THING.
>> Tucker: I AGREE WITH YOU.
THE INDUSTRY IS ON THE VERGE OF
A COLLAPSE AND YET WE ARE BEING
FLOODED WITH FOREIGN OIL, OUR
REFINERIES ARE BEING FLOODED
WITH FOREIGN OIL.
WHY ARE WE ALLOWING THAT?
>> YOU BRING UP AN INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND HERE’S WHAT
I WOULD DO, AND I WOULD
CERTAINLY GET THIS ADVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
I WOULD FOR THE NEXT 60-90 DAYS,
NOT FROM NOW ON BUT FOR THE NEXT
60 TO 90 DAYS, I WAS A
REFINER’S, WE WILL REFINE U.S.
CRUDE, U.S. CRUDE ONLY AND THAT
WOULD GIVE A BUFFER TO THE
MARKET AND SENT A CLEAR MESSAGE
THAT WE ARE JUST NOT GOING TO
LET FOREIGN OIL FLOW IN HERE AND
BLESS OUR ENERGY INDUSTRY.
AND HERE’S THE MORE IMPORTANT
THING.
TUCKER, NOT ONLY FOR YOUR
VIEWERS, THIS IS ABOUT OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
THIS IS ABOUT AMERICA’S ABILITY
TO DEFEND OURSELVES.
IF OUR INDEPENDENT OPERATORS WHO
HAVE LED THE SHELL REVOLUTION
AND WHO HAVE MADE AMERICA NUMBER
ONE GAS PRODUCING COUNTRY IN THE
WORLD, IF WE LOST THAT, WE WOULD
GO BACK TO 197475.
I WAS A PILOT IN THE
UNITED STATES AIR FORCE AT THAT
PERIOD OF TIME AND I REMEMBER
WHAT THAT WAS LIKE, WE WERE
BEHOLDEN TO COUNTRY WHO DIDN’T
NECESSARILY HAVE OUR BEST
INTEREST IN MIND.
YOU CANNOT AFFORD THAT.
>> Tucker: OF COURSE.
AND I DON’T KNOW WHY WE WOULD
ALLOW OUR FAKE ALLIES THE SAUDIS
TO FLOOD OUR MARKET RIGHT NOW.
I HOPE THAT YOUR RECOMMENDATION
IS ACTED UPON.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR JOINING US.
>> I HOPE WE WILL TALK ABOUT THE
TREASURY DEPARTMENT BUYING OIL
FUTURES.
I THINK A LOT OF THESE THINGS
MAY BE ABLE TO SAVE THE AMERICAN